hallo deutschland am gründonnerstag
herzlich willkommen zu unserem corona
kompakt viele werden jetzt im
osterurlaub daraus wird aber nix viele
fragen sind deswegen offen und die
beantwortet gleich unser rechtsexperte
erstmal keine lockerungen der auflagen
das hat die kanzlerin heute gesagt
normalerweise herrscht im april
hochbetrieb auf sylt in zeiten von
corona ist es aber einsam auf der insel
geworden nur noch einheimische sind
unterwegs mit den touristen ist deren
hauptverdienst quelle weggebrochen
für uns einen desaster wenn wir uns
anschauen dass wir normalerweise zu
seinen acht prozent des jahres
geschäftes machen
50.000 übernachtungen werden uns dieses
jahr fehlen
das ist schon eine ganz ganz große zahl
die viele viele ja wirtschaftlich
herausfordern wird
für sylt gilt eine zugangssperre auch
für diejenigen die hier ihren
zweitwohnsitz haben aber längst nicht
alle halten sich an die vorschriften
wir menschen sind ganz ganz kreativ auf
jeden fall und alle fälle hier
aufzuzählen würde den rahmen sprengen
habe bemerkt schönen tag für tag das ist
immer neue versuche gibt zuschauen wie
kann nicht begründen
trotz der zugangssperren erfüllt doch
zugang zu finden und die freiheit der
menschen bleibt eingeschränkt nicht nur
auf sylt immerhin soll die maßnahmen
nicht verschärft werden
die zahl der aktuell infizierten geht
ein wenig zurück wenn man die schon
wieder gesundeten abzieht und leider
eben auch die die ihr leben verloren
haben durch diese pandemie will noch mal
daran erinnern wenn das am tag 200 oder
mehr menschen sind dann sind das einfach
doch zahlen die uns nicht kalt lassen
können nach erhebungen der johns hopkins
universität sind in deutschland stand
heute 16 uhr 30 113 1296 infektionen
durch tests bestätigt 46.300 menschen
gelten als genesen
[Musik]
musikalisches dankeschön in zeiten von
corona ein ständchen für die mutter vor
einem chemnitzer altenheim
ich spiele ungefähr seit 14 tagen hier
vorm fans normaler mutter und weil wir
das heim als bestimmten gründen nicht
mehr betreten dürfen
und da habe ich überlegt musik war schon
immer ihre leidenschaft wir haben bei
ihrer blockflöte gelernt und die anfänge
des klaviers und jetzt bin ich einfach
was zurückgeben wenn sie nicht mehr
unterdorf auch im tierreich versucht man
das beste aus der lage zu machen
so können sich die pandas jüngling und
lily endlich ihrer sexualität widmen
nach 13 jahren ausschließlich
freundschaftliche beziehung möglich wird
das weil in diesem hongkonger zu virus
bedingt die besucher ausbleiben schlecht
für das menschliche personal
inspirierend für die tierische besatzung
ob der sex am ende auch zu nachwuchs
führt das ist frühestens in zweieinhalb
monaten klar dass erwandern bestimmt
hier unser zdf rechtsexperte dr felix
zimmermann ist heute unser gast und
urlaubsreisen die nicht stattfinden
können sind heute unser thema was
passiert denn mit gebuchten reisen
bekomme ich da dann nur gutscheine
zurück überall noch ist diese gutschein
lösungen nicht in kraft
noch gilt wer eine reise gebucht hat und
dieses studiert bekommt sein geld zurück
aber die bundesregierung versucht das
gestern hat sie ja auf den weg gebracht
das für veranstaltung theatertickets
sport tickets konzerttickets die
gutscheinlösung gilt also statt den
kaufpreis bekommt man jetzt noch einen
gutschein und das soll jetzt auch für
reisen kommen und auch für flugtickets
aber da geht es nicht so einfach denn da
ist europarecht im weg da muss man sich
jetzt erstmal auf europäischer ebene
noch einigen und die regel sieht er ganz
klar bei flügen die storniert werden da
gibt es das geld zurück und bereisen
auch mal sehen ob da die kommission
mitmachen wenn ja dann kommt leider für
die verbraucher die gutscheinlösung auch
für reisen in vielen dank sie werden
gleich noch weitere zuschauer fragen für
uns beantworten
in der gastronomie läuft momentan so gut
wie nix in den supermärkten dafür umso
mehr verlegt es ja passt schon nah dass
viele die branche wechseln wo bisher der
arbeitsplatz die bar oder der
schnellimbiss waren
werden jetzt regale beim discounter
eingeräumt eigentlich servieren am
rebecca und jana jovanovic sonst
cocktails tapas und dörfer er in einem
nachtclub sie in einem restaurant
doch alles dazu deshalb haben sie
kurzfristig die branche gewechselt und
helfen jetzt bei aldi auch ein bisschen
was anderes habe nicht völlig milch oder
butter oder wenn ich eine andere
abteilung wie nudeln oder obst
einzuliefern
und in der gastronomie das essen raus
oder kenne das ist dann so ein bisschen
die abweichung aber man hat halt vorsitz
im kundenkontakt sind beide anstrengende
das kann man sagen
eine unterweisung in arbeitsschutz eine
kurze einarbeitungsphase danach geht es
direkt los
die mitarbeiter in der filiale in
ennepetal bei hagen sind froh über die
unterstützung
denn in den supermärkten ist deutlich
mehr los als sonst und auch immer kaufen
viele menschen große mengen ein
deutlich öfter darüber sonst am tag ist
da jetzt beispielsweise die konserven
einmal aus dem lager ausholen um die
stellflächen im laden zu erfüllen müssen
wir dann im moment zwei dreimal betreibt
und das macht einfach aus dass wir
deutlich mehr arbeit haben und
dementsprechend sind wir sehr froh dass
wieder verstärkung recht haben waren
einrollen verkauf logistik die
supermarktketten suchen zurzeit dringend
neue mitarbeiter beziehungsweise
aushilfskräfte rede etwa bemüht sich und
studenten deren hochschulen geschlossen
sind und die großen lebensmittelketten
wenden sich gezielt an touristik und
gastronomie unternehmen die ihre
mitarbeiter momentan nicht beschäftigen
können um ihnen eben aushilfsjobs
anzubieten
so schnell wie möglich soll alles über
die bühne gehen teilweise haben wir es
wirklich in der richtig guten zeit von
24 stunden schon geschafft dass wir
wirklich den bewerbungs eingang ich den
geprüft habe wie ein telefoninterview
ein kurzes auch gemacht haben um einmal
auch abzustecken passt das auch für
beide seiten
und dann sind wir auch schon zur
einstellungen gekommen in der filiale
persönlich damit auch der bewerber
natürlich einmal sehen kann wie läuft es
überhaupt in der filiale ab weil das
dann doch nochmal kundensicht und
mitarbeiter hat sich nochmal einen
unterschied gibt supermärkte kunden neue
mitarbeiter alle seiten profitieren denn
rebecca und jana jovanovic thimphu
das ist für sie nun eben hier weiter
liegt dann erstmal froh dass man arbeit
gefunden hat und dieses schwierigen lage
bin aber trotzdem ein wirklich
glückliches angekommen zu sein
gott sei dank von dem team auch wirklich
sehr sehr herzlich aufgenommen von ihnen
wissen geld und ich habe mal wieder was
zu tun um bin ich den ganzen tag zu
hause mit der familie kann ja auch mal
ein bisschen anstrengend sein und man
hat einfach so zu verlieren
in ihren alten job steht noch alles
still sie sind froh jetzt hier etwas zu
tun zu haben
desinfektionsmittel und atemschutzmasken
sind das neue gold zumindest scheint
dass gerade so und die kassenärztliche
vereinigung hamburg hat davon eine
großlieferung bekommen das lager ist
streng geheim aus angst vor dieben die
auslieferung an ärzte und psychologen
psychotherapeuten läuft endlich 68.000
schutzmasken eingetaucht von der
kassenärztlichen vereinigung für 52.000
hamburger ärzte und psychotherapeuten in
eigenregie der einkauf auf dem weltmarkt
ist aktuell ein bild west die preise
erinnern sich nahezu stündlich ist ein
schwierig zwischen seriösen und
unseriösen händlern zu unterscheiden
medizinische schutzausrüstung auf den
weltmarkt zu besorgen ist momentan
unglaublich kompliziert eine bestellung
kam erst gar nicht an
sie wurde in ausland abgefangen für
verhandelt im moment über eine weitere
lieferung und doch bin ich gestern abend
mit der forderung konfrontiert worden
dass ich ganz persönlich über mehrere
millionen euro haften soll damit wir
überhaupt ausgesprochen dürfte das sind
sie im moment die rahmenbedingungen
unter denen wir uns bewegen
verteilt wird auch dringend benötigt es
desinfektionsmittel 80.000 flaschen
gespendet von einem hamburger
unternehmen alles ist so kostbar dass es
an einem geheimen ort gelagert und von
dort aus verteilt wird ein
sicherheitsunternehmen bedacht die
lagerhalle einer spedition
mittlerweile lagern wie hier quasi das
neue gold ein so möchte ich mal ne ne
und dementsprechend muss der ort leider
geheim bleiben
darüber darf ich nicht weiter
ausgeliehen reichen wird das alles nur
wenige wochen es fehlen noch kittel die
zurzeit besonders schwer zu beschaffen
sind ausreichend schutzausrüstung für
die ärzte in hamburger praxen zu
besorgen das bleibt für die vereinigung
der kassen ärzte auch weiterhin ein
abenteuer
eigentlich wäre ich jetzt auch im urlaub
genau genommen in ägypten aber es geht
ja gar nichts mehr
oder es gibt tatsächlich noch menschen
die im flugzeug sitzen oder bahn fahren
wie geht es den flug und zugbegleitern
in der aktuellen situation wir haben
genau das heraus gefunden natürlich mit
mundschutz und mit sicherheitsabstand
flug lh 183 von berlin nach frankfurt
ist zum einsteigen bereit
[Musik]
kurz zuvor habe ich meine reise dort
unten begonnen am flughafen berlin tegel
im vergangenen jahr waren hier 24
millionen passagiere
jetzt bin ich allein in der haupthalle
das ist wirklich so wo ich hier dass man
fast sprichwörtliche stecknadel fallen
hört auf dem vorfeld sind die meisten
jets dauerparker easyjet hat den betrieb
wegen corona komplett eingestellt andere
vielflieger erobern jetzt den flugplatz
zurück auf flug lh 183 nur noch drei
statt sonst 20 mal pro tag fliegt die
lufthansa gerade von berlin nach
frankfurt ich bin einer von 26
passagieren
das ist ja ruhig alle bemüht sich um
normalität aber ganz klar ist gar nichts
normal
die meisten an bord tragen schutzmasken
auch flugbegleiter mustafa demir walter
und seine kollegin anfangs noch wissen
komisch aber nachher zeit klappt das
schon reduzierter bordservice für
reduzierten passagier kontakt die
lufthansa hat ihr flugprogramm auf fünf
prozent heruntergefahren 87.000
mitarbeiter auf kurzarbeit gesetzt muss
dafür dem er bald er ist froh dass er
nicht allein von der fliegerei lebt er
arbeitet noch als altenpfleger ich bin
letzten ort fast gar nicht geflogen
der vorletzte flug für den monat und der
restlichen plan steht noch aus freien
tagen und nebenbei arbeiten punktlandung
auch hier am frankfurter flughafen ist
es extrem leer
ich bin gespannt wie es in der bahn
aussieht
ich begleite zugchef fonds und seine
kollegen im ece von frankfurt nach
berlin
achten sie auf abstand zu mitreißenden
unseren kollegen gesucht
[Musik]
die duh trikots aus berlin kommen gerade
aus neuseeland kommt die sonne
mitgebracht
erst traumreise dann albtraum drei
wochen mussten sie in quarantäne auf
einen rückflug warten jetzt stecken
ihnen 35 stunden reise in den knochen
letzte etappe und wir waren uns sicher
dass wir für einen expresszug keine
platzkarten brauchen so war ich so etwas
gewöhnt und als vorhin am
informationsschalter erkundigt haben er
sagte uns der bahnmitarbeiter sie
brauchen keine platzkarten das ist alles
entspannt sie können einfach einsteigen
in seinen 25 jahren als zugbegleiter hat
ja und frost schnee und stürme erlebt
und sich hunderte male mit lustigen
sprüchen für verspätungen entschuldigt
jetzt wartet er in leipzig auf fahrgäste
und wartet
und guckt
und kanada man kann sie nicht dran
gewöhnen
ich fühle mich auch nicht dran gewöhnen
jetzt weiß ich nicht
das ist meine welt deine welt sind volle
ece 700 menschen eng an eng doch heute
ist wieder mal alles corona
zurzeit haben wir zehn fahrgäste in der
ersten klasse und 62 fahrgast in der 2
die bahn fährt trotz 15 prozent
auslastung weiter fasst das volle
programm wagen 7 gehört heute einem
jungen lehrer der gerade seinen umzug
von berlin nach tübingen managen muss
sich ein bisschen seltsam an weil so ein
bisschen auch so eine art schuldgefühl
es gegenüber den mitarbeitenden von der
deutschen bahn weil ich hoffentlich ein
grund habe der gut genug ist zu reisen
dann gleichzeitig denke ich mir so wo
sind die ganzen anderen menschen die
kontakt beschränkungen wirken
zugleiter jörn fonds hat jetzt viel zeit
für den blick nach draußen aus dem
leeren zug auf eine leere autobahn unser
rechtsexperte dr felix zimmermann
beantwortet ihre fragen rund ums reisen
zum beispiel von klaus der schreibt
unsere gebuchte pauschalreise wurde von
tui am 28 03 stunden jetzt bekommen wir
unser geld innerhalb von 14 tagen zurück
oder müssen wir auch ein voucher also
ein gutschein akzeptieren falls es gibt
ja sagt er eben noch ist diese
gutscheinlösung nicht in kraft für
reisen
aber die veranstalter die spiele
natürlich auf zeit die wissen dass etwas
in der pipeline in der politik und wir
versuchen eben ja die kunden hin zu
halten und ein bisschen zeit zu schinden
wo eben in der hoffnung dass die bald
kommt die rutsche lösung
aktuell muss man sie nicht akzeptieren
hat bei einer stornierung das recht den
ganzen reisepreis zurück zu bekommen
also kann man auch darauf bestehen dass
man jetzt sein geld bekommt das kann man
aber das problem ist ja dass dann diese
regelung der bundesregierung oder wenn
das parlament die absichten dann auch
rückwirkend gelten wird so dass man sich
dann letztlich wahrscheinlich doch mit
dem gutschein zufrieden stellen muss
aber noch wissen wir ja nicht ob die eu
damit macht also noch würde ich sie
vorschlagen weil eben auch wirklich auf
den die rückerstattung bestellen rainer
tschersich fragt wir haben für anfang
juni eine ostsee kreuzfahrt gebucht und
bei der buchung eine anzahlung geleistet
können der die am 2 mai fällig
restzahlung zurückbehalten wegen der
unklaren lage im juni in den betroffenen
ländern genau restzahlung da sind jetzt
zwei aspekte hier angesprochen werden
erstens zweiter mai ist noch außerhalb
der reisewarnung des auswärtigen amtes
die gebnis ende april
das heißt man kann ja nicht sagen ja wir
möchten gerne in den reisepreis zurück
wegen der reisewarnung
andererseits ist ja extrem
wahrscheinlich dass die verlängert wird
hat sich nichts geändert
bis zum zweiten mal und da gibt es im
bgb eine sogenannte einrede der
unsicherheit wenn mit großer
wahrscheinlichkeit klar ist dass die
gegenseite den vertrag nicht erfüllen
wird also hier die reise am zweiten mal
eh nicht stattfinden kann
dann kann man dort zu raten
verbraucherschützer auch ihm sagen nein
ich behalte mir das geld zurück aber
gänzlich rechtssicher ist das nicht aber
die verbraucherschützer empfehlen dass
die kunden erst mal auf diesem par kraft
321 bgb hinweisen okay norbert göttler
fragt unsere wohnwagen stehen in italien
unser wohnwagen und wir würden ihn gerne
wieder zurück nach deutschland holen
wenn wir ohne kontakte in italien und
österreich bleiben ist dann eine
rückholung möglich also quasi eine
rettungsmission für den gestrandeten
wohnwagen
die könnten recht zeitaufwendig werden
denn erstmal muss man nach österreich
und dann war italien wonach österreich
darf man wohl durch reisen wenn man eben
doch nicht bleibt aber in italien gilt
schon mal 14 tage 14 tage quarantäne
also muss man auch schon mal 14 tage
warten wenn wir nicht ein besonders
triftigen grund hat ich glaube nicht
dass die rückholung des wohnwagens
dazugehört na ja und da muss man ja noch
zurück nach deutschland und gilt ab
morgen in deutschland wahrscheinlich
auch diese 14-tägige quarantäne
wenn jetzt kein triftiger grund für die
aussage vorlage also das könnte ein
großes und langjähriges abenteuer aber
es ist möglich ist da hat mal sehr
langes kuhn fragt werden ein kurztrip
für mitte märz an die mosel gebucht zwei
tage vorher dann storniert wir wollen
gerne wissen ob das hotel und trotz der
korona krise 90 prozent stornokosten in
rechnung stellen darf
über diesen hotelbuchung auch innerhalb
deutschlands muss man jetzt genau gucken
mitte märz weiß ich jetzt nicht genau
was ist schon der zeitpunkt wo die
gesetze gesagt haben hotels dürfen gar
nicht mehr zu touristischen zwecken
heute beherbergen wenn das der fall ist
wenn das damals schon galt dann kriegt
man auch sein geld zurück muss keine
stornierungskosten kaufen denn dann war
die leistung ja gar nicht gar nicht
angeboten
wenn es davor war man hat storniert aus
irgendwelchen anderen gründen aus angst
oder irgendwas dann muss man die sterne
kosten auch tragen und hat das recht
gehabt dann vielen dank für die
beantwortung der fragen und unser corona
kompakt das finden sie auch auf youtube
auf dem kanal der heute.de wenn auch sie
eine frage an unsere experten haben dann
schicken sie uns sehr gerne eine mail an
corona kompakt zdf de einige davon die
werden wir dann hier im studio
beantworten